The jogan Experience so what is going on
with this drug-free sport thing I don't
know but I love
it is it drug free sport and and is
their logo a
wink Oh you mean they have another
commission yeah they got rid of usada
but usada went dirty on them man oh
usada messed up when they when they when
they went and uh did that statement
without notifying Dana White my first
tweet was like oh you s [__] up they
really [__] up they said they were
doing it for McGregor so they could get
Conor McGregor and not have to test him
that's what they ins try to make Dana
look bad which is not true because Don
Conor McGregor entered into the usada
pool and supplied two test so far so
they're wrong what they said was wrong
he's not on anything he's clean they
tested him I didn't know what what did
you to say what did they say they said
that the reason why the UFC is leaving
this relationship with usada was because
they were trying to do something with
Conor B on to Conor and then they said
it money issue which we know it's not
his lawyer said he's the most tested
fighter of all time in the USC as far as
Conor McGregor's concerned really I
don't think that's true
ially Pao Costa was the most tested yeah
Paulo I know y's tested a ton all the
dudes that look juicy they go yeah but
can we agree usada is good for certain
Sports when it comes to the UF UFC it's
been a disaster it's been a disaster the
problem they were waking guys up at 6:30
in the morning on their [__] weigh-in
day they were doing crazy [__] like that
trying to get samples day of the fight
you got to report 365 days a year and
you're sub you're a sub contractor it it
doesn't make a lot of it doesn't fit the
business model of the UFC all good so
now they have this guy from at who rolls
with the boys maybe a little assai
himself and he's like yeah he's good and
I'm like I like that guy yeah [__] yeah
yeah but there's a interest potentially
if it an at fighter 2022 Yuri Pro hoska
was tested 64 times God wow so he's the
most last year I mean I don't know about
all time I wonder why they tested him
that's harassment that's [__]
harassment well he fights like he's on
meth